it is the honor and the privilege of my
life to be elected as leader of the
Labour Party it comes at a moment like
none other in our lifetime coronavirus
has brought normal life to a halt our
cities our towns and our villages are
silent our roads deserted public life
has all but come to a standstill and
we're missing each other people are
frightened by the strangeness anxious
about what will happen next and we have
to remember that every number is a
family shaken to its foundation unable
even to carry out the most poignant of
ceremonies a funeral in the way that
they would like it reminds us of how
precious life is but also how fragile it
reminds us of what really matters our
family our friends our relationships the
love we have for one another our health
our connections with those that we don't
know a greeting from a stranger a kind
word from a neighbor these makeup
society they remind us that we share our
lives together we have to trust one
another and look after one another
and I could see this happening people
coming together to help the isolated and
the vulnerable checking on their
neighbors so many volunteering for the
NHS millions of people doing their bit
to stop this virus and to save lives our
willingness to come together like this
as a nation has been lying dormant for
too long when millions of us stepped out
onto our doorsteps to applaud the carers
visibly moved there was hope of a better
future
times like this we need good government
a government that saves lives and
protects our country it's a huge
responsibility of whether we voted for
this government or not we all rely on it
to get this right that's why in the
national interest the Labor Party will
play its full part under my leadership
we will engage constructively with the
government not opposition for
opposition's sake not scoring party
political points or making impossible
demands but with the courage to support
where that's the right thing to do
but we will test the arguments that are
put forward
we will shine a torch on critical issues
and where we see mistakes or faltering
government or things not happening as
quickly as they should
we'll challenge that and call that out
our purpose when we do that is the same
as the government's to save lives and to
protect our country a shared purpose but
that is not the only task for the Labor
Party the weeks ahead are going to be
really difficult I fear there are going
to be some awful moments for many of us
but we will get through this the curve
will flatten the wards will empty the
immediate threat will subside and we
have scientists working on vaccines but
when we do get through this we cannot go
back to business as usual this virus has
exposed the fragility in our society
it's lifted a curtain too many will have
given too much some of us will have lost
too much we know in our hearts things
are going to have to change we can see
so clearly now who the key workers
really are when we get through this
it'll be because of our NHS staff our
care workers our ambulance drivers our
emergency services our cleaners our
porters
it will be because of the hard work and
bravery of every key worker as they took
on this virus and kept our country going
for too long they've been taken for
granted and poorly paid they were last
and now they should be first in their
courage and their sacrifice and their
bravery we can see a better future this
crisis has brought out the resilience
and human spirit in all of us we must go
forward with a vision of a better
society built on that resilience and
built on that human spirit that will
require bravery and change in our party
as well I want to thank Rebecca and Lisa
for running such passionate and powerful
campaigns and for their friendship and
support along the way I want to thank
our Labor Party staff who worked really
hard on my own amazing campaign team
full of positivity that unifying spirit
I want to pay tribute to Jeremy Corbyn
who led our party through some really
difficult times
who energized our movement and who's a
friend as well as a colleague and to all
of our members supporters and affiliates
I say this whether you voted for me or
not I will represent you I will listen
to you and I will bring our party
together but we have to face the future
with honesty anti-semitism has been a
stain on our party I have seen the grief
that it's brought to so many Jewish
communities on behalf of the Labor Party
I am sorry and I will tear out this
poison by its roots and judge success by
the return of our Jewish members and
those who felt that they could no longer
support us the Labor Party isn't
and powerful force for good together
with those that went before us we've
changed the lives of millions of people
for the better we created the NHS we
created the welfare state
we passed a qualities legislation the
race relations act we set up the Open
University we built hospitals and
schools established Shore start and
played our part in bring about peace in
Northern Ireland but we've just lost
four elections in a row with failing in
our historic purpose he had no doubt I
understand the scale of the task the
gravity of the position that we're in
we've got a mountain to climb but we
will climb it and I will do my utmost to
reconnect us across the country to
re-engage with our communities and
voters to establish a coalition across
our towns now cities and our regions
with all Creed's and communities to
speak for the whole of the country where
that requires change we will change
where that requires us to rethink we
will rethink our mission has to be to
restore trust in our party as a force
for good and a force for change this is
my pledge to the British people I will
do my utmost to guide us through these
difficult times to serve all of our
communities and to strive for the good
of our country I will lead this great
party into a new era with confidence and
with hope so that when that time comes
we can serve our country again in
government